So let's start actually getting our sequence set up
and adding our actors to our sequence.
So to keep consistency, we're going
to create a new folder called SEQ underscore EX for example.
So we'll create that, and then we'll create a new level
sequence as well.
So jump back to our project, and I'm
going to go ahead and just delete our classroom
folder and the level sequence, which is totally fine.
Go back to my sequence 105, and I'm
going to right click under here, do new folder,
and we'll call this SEQ underscore EX for example.
We'll double click to go into this folder,
and again, we can create a new level sequence
by clicking the little dropdown here and add level sequence.
Let me go ahead and delete this one from there.
Or we can also do it through our content browser,
but because we do want this in our scene,
let's go ahead and just do add level sequence.
And we jump back.
We're going to name this to SEQ underscore 105 EX for example.
So go into our example folder, and we'll
call this SEQ underscore 105 EX for example, click Save.
And because we use that dropdown,
it will automatically place it into our world.
So I'm going to fly into here real quick,
and let's just move it kind of in the center
of our little stage here, just
so we know that this is where the action is
going to be occurring in case we need to open this quickly.
And you see as well that it went ahead and just
automatically opened our sequence
with the sequence active.
If at any point you close your sequence, don't worry.
That's totally fine.
A couple of ways we can do this, we can click
the actual icon in the world.
So we can see here, sequence 105 EX
and click open level sequence.
Or we can go back to our content browser
underneath here and just double click it,
and we'll open up our sequence.
All right, perfect.
So the first step that we want to do after creating
our sequence is start staging some of our actors.
Now if you recall, we can do spawnables.
We can access content that's already in the level.
But for the purposes of what we're building here,
we're actually going to drag the actors into the world
first, and then we're going to add them to our sequence.
And the reason for that is if I jump over,
eventually our whole shot will kind of
culminate to this little point here in the map.
But we want to start way in the building in the back.
So if I were just to simply drag the little bot
character into the sequence, it would place it
at 0, 0, 0 on our origin, which
is not really what I want.
So I'm going to go to my content browser.
Now in this case, it's going to be a little difficult
to try to drag back and forth.
So I'm just going to dock this in my layout.
There we go.
So we've got this, and I'm going
to drag it off and move it to the side here.
Perfect.
OK, so what we're going to look for actually
is this little SKM bot.
You'll see it's in the characters bot mesh.
I'll show you a little shortcut here,
where we're just going to search for SKM underscore bot
by clicking our root content folder,
and I'm going to do SKM underscore.
You'll see bot.
And what I'm going to do is drag him into our level here.
Now just to show you real quick,
go ahead and keep yours in the level itself.
But if I delete this and drag it into our sequence,
you'll see that it in fact does put it at our 0, 0
location, even though it is in our sequence, which
is not what we want.
So we're going to drag him back up to our stage here.
Now what we want to do is actually add this actor
to our sequence.
And that's very easy to do is inside of our sequence,
we can simply right click, Add Actor to Sequence.
So I'll have my SKM bot selected.
And inside of my sequence in the content section
here on the left, right click, Add Actor to Sequence.
Now you will notice that we have
all of the content within our actual level present here.
We could even do a search.
I could do SKM.
There's the SKM bot.
Or you'll see because we have the asset selected inside
of the level already, it's the first thing
that's available here.
So I'll just go ahead and click this.
And you'll see now it's added to our sequence.
And now we can start manipulating it and changing it
as we need.
The next thing you want to do is actually
convert this to a spawnable.
With the character in the world right now,
he actually exists.
So even if I closed my sequence,
so I'm going to just save this and close my sequence,
you'll see that the bot stays within the world, which
is not what we want because players would see this.
They could interact with it.
They could run into it, which is not really what we want.
We just want this actor present inside of the sequence itself.
So again, I could go back up to,
I could find my sequence in the world here.
Or I could simply just drop down sequence 105X, open it,
and now we have our bot.
So I'm going to right click on it.
And what I want to do is convert to spawnable.
So as soon as I do that, you'll
see that it changes to a lightning bolt.
We can confirm that in our outliner.
Save my sequence.
And if I close the sequence, you'll
see that the character disappears.
Again, one of the advantages of using
our spawnables versus possessables.
So he only exists as long as this sequence is open.
Now that our actor is present inside of our sequence,
we want to go ahead and add some animation to it.
So to do that, we're going to click the asset itself
and add an animation.
Now, the first one that we want to add is this run.
So from the final sequence that we'll have,
we want the character to run to the end of the platform,
jump, and then free fall.
So we're going to use three separate animations.
The first one's starting with the run.
So I'm going to go ahead and take the character.
And with my rotation snapping on, I'm
going to rotate him 90 degrees
so he's facing the end of the platform.
So I'm going to select the asset.
I can also select it from the sequence.
And you'll see animation here.
I'm going to keep my play head at 0, 0, 0, which
if you want a quick snap, we can actually just
do this to front, to the front of the sequence.
Click my animation, a little plus,
and I'm going to look for run.
We should see a bot run.
So go ahead and add this to the animation.
You see that the character already has some movement.
Let's go and do this.
And if I play the sequence, you'll
see he plays the animation once, and that's it.
So the next thing that we want to do
is actually extend this out.
Now, in this case, let's extend it out
to about 150 frames.
We may adjust this later.
So I'm going to highlight over my animation, which
is this a bot run, and click and drag the end here to 150.
And you see now, if I scrub this back and hit play,
you see that he actually plays his animation,
continues to cycle over.
So now what we want to do is actually
add some key frames to make it look like the character is
actually running.
So we're going to set one key frame at the start,
and we're going to key our location, rotation, and scale.
And we're going to use our key frame to change.
So if any of those properties change,
to automatically key frame as well.
Or we could just simply add a key frame manually.
All right, so let's jump back over to our sequence.
So I'm going to roughly put the character.
Now, he is slightly off, so I'm going to rotate him about,
do 10 degrees.
So now he's lined up with the end here, select the SKM bot.
I'm going to expand out my transforms here,
and click this little plus button to add a key frame.
Now, it's important, wherever your time slider is located
is where it's going to add those key frames.
So let's say that I add key frames at 61 frames.
Not a problem.
I can just select them all and drag them back to zero.
All right, so this is our starting position.
And let's go ahead and move forward about 90 frames.
And then if you have this create key frame automatically
turned on, if I then press W to go into move.
And if I move my character, you'll
notice that we get something interesting here.
So we get a point, which is the start of our key.
And this is the end where we created this new key.
So if I didn't have auto key frame turned on,
it wouldn't automatically create this key.
So make sure that if you don't, go ahead
and click the little plus button again
to create your keys.
Now, an important note here, you'll
notice that our location, rotation, and scale all
have keys.
However, location only has a new key.
And that's because the only location that really changed
was my x and y.
The character never went vertically.
He just went x and y.
Hence why we only have these two additional keys.
So just to keep that in mind.
So if we go back to the beginning here
and we play our animation, you'll
see that he kind of starts to ramp up and out.
And then he stops, which is what we want.
Now, if you notice, there's something
a little weird about this opening animation
that he kind of starts to run, get some velocity,
and then he's up to speed, which is not really
what we want.
We want him hitting the ground running.
So to do that, we're actually going
to change our key frames, these first ones.
So I'm going to click drag over these.
And then right click, I'm going
to change the key interpolation to linear.
So I'll come back to this in a second and explain.
But now if we go back to the front and press play,
you see that he's already running.
And that doesn't look too bad.
Now, something else to note here
is that because of our key frames,
you'll see that he starts to slow down towards the end.
So we'll do the same thing.
We will select this key frame, right click,
and change it to linear.
And so now, if we play back the animation,
looks like he's running right to the end, which is perfect.
That's exactly what we need.
So the next step here is to go ahead and add
two additional animations.
So we're going to add the jump and then the fall.
So we'll do that really quickly.
And then we'll work on our key frame.
So I'm going to go back to here.
And what I'm going to do is let's take our A bot run.
And we know that from this movement, he runs to the end.
And at this key frame, we want him to jump.
So I'm going to take this handle,
drag it back right to our key frame.
And then I'm going to go ahead and click animation.
Let's expand this out.
I'm going to add another animation.
And in this case, we are looking
for jump, which is a bot run jump.
And you'll see that it adds, if I move this off,
you'll see it adds a secondary animation to our set.
So go ahead and undo that real quick.
So now, if we play this back, we'll see that he runs.
And then he jumps.
But if you'll notice that the animation is just
the character's jump.
I'm not going to open the animation.
But essentially, it doesn't have any translation information
as the character jumps.
Let's go ahead and move down to the end here.
So there's our jump animation.
And then after the jump animation,
let's click another plus here.
And we're looking for our, go back here,
A underscore bot underscore fall.
So click a little plus.
Should be the top there, A bot fall.
And now we have this.
And of course, I could clip this back at 150.
So he runs, jumps.
And then he's in this falling animation.
So the next thing that we need to do is actually translate
the character with the jump.
So I'm going to go about halfway into the jump here,
so about maybe 100 frames.
And with my move selected, my Auto Key turned on,
I'm going to go ahead and just move the character up
as if he's jumping off.
And you'll notice that the curve gives us a little preview
here of what's going to happen.
So he translates.
But he's actually walking uphill,
which is not what we want.
So I'm going to undo to remove that key.
And what I'm going to do is actually jump to our key here,
little shortcut.
If you hold down Shift,
it'll actually snap to the next key frame.
So I'm holding down Shift and dragging my timeline,
expand out my transform, another location.
You'll see that in fact, we don't have a key for Z.
That's why this goes up.
So I can simply click a little plus button
and you see it adds a key in my Z direction.
Perfect.
So let's go back to our frame 100,
we'll go over here
and I will kind of put the bot somewhere in the air.
And now you can see that we have that motion.
We'll go to the end.
Now in this case, because he's going to be falling,
I'm going to go ahead and just move this to somewhere.
I can just go to the end
and let's move the character all the way down.
So now he's jumped.
Go back and let's play our animation
so we can see he runs, jumps and falls.
Now not the greatest on movement,
but that's very easy to do.
We can go here, move some of our key frames.
I probably need to change my interpolation
because this is linear.
So it's just straight up and down.
So I'm going to select these three keys right here,
which is the peak of our jump, right click on it.
And let's just go ahead and change it to cubic auto.
And we should see at least a little bit of gradation.
So now if we go to play, he jumps and starts to fall.
Perfect.
I think that's shaping up to look fairly good.
So we know that our camera is going to be
from this position right here.
So I'm going to move it into position
and just take a look to see if this feels natural.
All right, perfect.
So this juncture,
he does kind of hang in the air a little too long.
So we can take these keys
and simply just slide them back
and possibly move our end key so he falls faster.
And now if we play,
we get something that feels much better.
Perfect.
So now we have our shot essentially established
with his movement jumping off of our platform.